يقال أنه كان هناك تباين كبير جدًا بين أعمال العنف
الرعب والقتل وكل ما حدث للأصدقاء
ملفوفين بالاختطاف وهم لحظة العبور إلى غزة
ومدخل الأنفاق هو في الأساس نفس عملية تشغيل القرص المرن
الإرهابيين وفي الواقع يصبح شكلاً من أشكال انتقال العدوى
هذا بدون تهديدات بالأسلحة وبدون عنف لمجرد ذلك
لم تعد هناك حاجة لسماع أنك تعرف مثل
التي تجعل الدوريات ساعة في الساحة لتنويرهم بالفرق
ولم أسمع في السجون عن شيء كهذا على حد علمي
قوي تحت الأرض في الصالات أو الأنفاق وجميعها
هذه المرة سألت أيضًا عن التفاعلات
مع الإرهابيين قام الإرهابيون بتوظيفهم مرة أخرى
ليس لدينا سوى فرق بين الجنود والمدنيين
المواطنون الذين تم إطلاق سراحهم حتى الآن وأنتم أيضًا لدينا
والدين من جيديش، لكني لم أسمعك أيضًا
هذا هو المكان الذي لم أسمع فيه عن التحقيقات، ولم أسمع عنه
التعذيب: لم أسمع عن أعمال عنف من الإرهابيين
ولم أسمع عن الكثير من التفاعل على الإطلاق
أقول، أذكركم أن الكثير من المختطفين لا يفعلون ذلك
يتم التحدث باللغة العربية ومعظم الإرهابيين لا يفعلون ذلك
العبرية أو الإنجليزية ثم نسبة إلى فهمي الماعز
كان هناك القليل من التفاعل ولكن مرة أخرى أعتقد
الصورة كلها بالطبع جدا جدا
جزئيا ويتم احتجازهم في مجموعات ويتم احتجازهم
في المجموعات أ
الجغرافيا القضية حتى الآن شوهد كلا من المختطفين و
يبدو أن الأمر يتعلق بالاختطاف في الجبال
حافظوا على تماسكهم وأعطاهم وأعطاهم وأعطاهم
لديهم الكثير من القوة منذ أن كانوا مع الأصدقاء
بالطبع هم أشخاص يعرفونهم وضعفاء
سمعت أن الطعام القليل المتعب لم يجعلهم جائعين
أنك طرحت سؤالا، لا يوجد، ليس هناك قصة حزن كبير
بالطبع الطعام
ديل